[Musica]
no sto guardando può forse scoperto la
camera ha scoperto la camera
farò un bello scherzetto vitale nel
nascondimento oggi camera da letto che
amaretto dove siamo noi ora siamo
corridoio e colori qualcosa e andato
bene le esperienze e voterò tantum che
vero vado in rosso devo dire che ti sta
molto bene in rosa porta a grandissima
richiesta dell'uomo di sodio nascondino
among per ogni turno dobbiamo peccare il
nostro ruolo da questo canto erode
peschiamo impostore dovremo cercare gli
altri crew menti sappiamo che i mezzi
dovremo andare a nascondersi
ok clemente devono tornare qua nella
cameretta del calderone e rimettere la
targhetta per castelleone che riescono a
farlo senza essere scoperti
dall'impostare andiamo vinta la partita
e anche questo video raggiungere i 20
mila mi piace ci sarà anche una terza
parte quindi scuole di cose non mi
seguite ancora su intendiamo andati a
seguirmi nome anita stories e se volete
seguitemi anche sentita oggi siamo rosso
rosa ciao ciao
inizia a pescare giallo prendi vediamo
cosa presa dalla presa
no io no ma si mangia bravo ok pezzo io
adesso lo stesso interessatissimo io
sono le bottoni pur di vedere un
filmetto finti fatica che io dovrò
trovare vitale e 134 giallo ha deciso di
dormire invece di andare a nasco come ti
nascondo io allora o almeno meno esposto
12 ok cosa si è allontanato controlliamo
le camere vediamo dove sta andando il
nascondere fino a scorso dove sta
andando
e dietro alla porta
no ho deciso di cambiare dove sta
scendendo giù presto
eccolo sceso le scale sotto al tavolo
con le altre più in testa non si ferma
mai
penso che si sia messo qua dietro patate
testa ora scegliamo un'arma da impostore
e andiamo a prenderlo però facilissimo
vincere con le camere di sicurezza
giallo ma tu hai deciso di rimanere a
dormire
ok perché
[Musica]
grazie a questo torno lo ha deciso di
fare un riposino oggi non ha molta
voglia di giocare con un può dormire
ecco che cosa ti uscito forse una chance
di essere impostore vediamo
[Applauso]
ok io inizio a contare allora briga di
renna 1 3 4 5 6 7 e tanto mi ce vole
armiamo questa la mia preferita a
lanciano ti lasciamo riposare
tranquillamente linee io vado a cercare
rosso in camera da letto
l'acs ancora più divertente che io posso
vedere con le camere di sicurezza dove
sta andando l'impostore e spostarmi a
nascondermi in un altro punto
controlliamo dove sta andando e se
questo video raggiungi 20 mila mi piace
il prossimo nascondino sarà nuovamente
con le camere di sicurezza
eccolo lo vedete
in corridoio
mi sta dando
sta facendo greta's ma perché
ha premuto ne emerge
forse si sta vicino tutto
l'abbiamo scampata per un pelo che ti
visto era qua in camera ma per fortuna
non ci ha visto nascosti qua adesso
controlliamo
ecco un soggiorno
ora che il soggiorno possiamo tornare in
studio e mettere la nostra targhetta del
calderone così avremmo vinto la tua
targhetta grazie
ora saluti a me che berlino ha omesso le
nostre targhette nel calderone abbiamo
vinto è giusto non è stato dappertutto
dove tiri nascosta io non lo posso dire
cosa è freddo niente mise niente stavo
guardando un video su youtube
no quello che sembrava il nostro
soggiorno mi stavi spiando superano un
video su youtube ma seguendo il nostro
soggiorno è una foto beh ora passiamo al
prossimo turno terzo round vestiamo dal
calderone tutti un po sospetta il
momento per stare ora pesca giallo dei
clienti giallo ha pescato nuovamente
quindi rimane solo 234 si sa che i
sediamo l'arma nel frattempo guardate
stanno anni corridoio che sta facendo e
sta andando vuole uscire fuori di casa
il reattore ma pensa davvero che
riuscirà a nascondersi sotto quel mini
tavolino ma non è tutto bene finchè
possiamo andare a prenderlo
prendiamo la nostra arma aspetta si sta
spostando cento crede davvero di poter
nascondere li ha cambiato idea
no sto guardando qua forse scoperto la
camera ha scoperto la camera
[Musica]
che succede
si è bloccato attaccato numero vediamo
le altre camere se funzionano ancora
sì le altre camere funzionano quindi è
scoperto solo quando nel corridoio
scoperto la camera nel corridoio in
electric e va staccata chiamo ci andiamo
a cercarlo prima che scopre anche le
altre parti anche le altre dove sarà
tanto rosa franco laqua in corridoi ed
elette ecco la camera ha staccato la
spina guardate
ha staccato la spina
li attacchiamo ora dovrebbe funzionare
rosa rosa mi ha chiuso a chiave mi aveva
fatto una trappola
l'ho chiusa chiusa con chiusa adesso
mettiamo il bigliettino dove il
bigliettino era quinta scappa ecco
bigliettino vigentino bigliettino e lo
mettiamo dentro il calderone a vita
adesso non mi resta che liberare
l'impostore visto che l'ho chiuso in
quella stanza abbia votiamo impostore
evento ogni inserito per inserito già mi
hai fregato questa volta questa volta di
toyota stiamo ora il prossimo turno e
vedrai quarto e ultimo rabbia
scrive forse allora un'altra possibilità
di essere impostore vediamo il motore
è giallo
mi sa che già lo ha un po di soldi per
dirci quindi forse riusciremo a vincere
come ok foglio in mano
adesso andiamo nasconderci mio zio pino
gli abbiamo detto che chiusero
permettere di sicurezza giallo
berlino è distratto che nascondeva
dietro e controllo le camere di
sicurezza
ok sono nascosta qua dietro le scale
vediamo dove si è nascosto rosa ma date
rosa e qua dietro alla porta in camera
da letto giallo sta andando cercarne
vediamo se lo trova ecco guardate lo sta
cercando
non vediamo se la trova
ma non ha trovato ancora guardate forse
se n'è accorto da piccolo ho trovato o
no sta tornando
[Musica]
bravissimi danno ora devi trovare rosa
giallo trovate il mio nascondiglio che
era là dietro ora vediamo se riesci a
trovare rosa fosse rosa avessi a
riportare il suo nome da crew mating ma
dove sta ricercando giallo non è stato
là sopra dai figli un indizio in camera
da letto ma non è il momento nulla mi ha
detto ti manca ancora prima è che da
trovare perché sto andando a cercarlo
trova e copertura
jamila romanzo l'impostore giallo a vita
e perotti punto il contesto stanno
arrivando
hai visto l'impostore giallo è stato
bravissimo a trovarti dietro la porta
tu come fai a sapere che stavo dietro la
porta e ho sentito il rumore di della
porta con un rumor avevano fatto il suo
umore le reti di rumori o berlino non mi
ha trovato nemmeno la prima volta avuto
un'origine saperlo ho indovinato un po
sas nel prossimo episodio indagherà un
meglio e queste tue conoscenze voi
lasciate un bel mi piace per un altro
episodio di nascondino among a
bravissimo giallo in portare ha vinto il
sì ha trovato subito
ora vi lasciamo qua 4 casoli nato qui
micara provvedere inoltre altri video
cliccate su quella che preferite
buona visione
[Musica]